I won fifty what's up y'all you're
[ __ ] dumb cute [ __ ] so today we're
doing a very special special event now
you guys know me I'm not I don't like
doing meat increase meaning greens
aren't my thing I think like if you put
up meet and greet out for people just to
meet you just because for the [ __ ] sakes
of people meeting you you're conceited
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh maybe not but it's not
my thing so I decided to develop
something called I'm eatin green and an
eating greens very different there's not
going to be a [ __ ] ton you guys here
it's going to be a select few and you
guys answered a few questions about why
you like food and the reason why we're
doing this eatin please because I get to
sit down share meal and the connect with
you so today we have a very special
guest and you guys seen it before in my
videos or have not but it's Stevie from
uh Stevie's BBQ the guy makes some of
the best barbecue I've ever had and this
is how I'm going to connect with you
guys sharing a meal talking sitting down
and really getting to know you versus
having this huge meet-and-greet where
all you guys just say hi I take a
picture and you know peace out we're
gonna talk we'll have a conversation
we're going to share some bomb-ass food
and you guys are gonna get to meet the
chef understand why he cooked through
the way he did it and we'll be getting a
little personal
so right now we're just doing a light
little snack we're doing future deviled
eggs so we take the yolks blend it with
some kimchi some Japanese Mayo some
mustard just a classic deviled egg mix
but just to really give it a little kick
we put in the kimchi and you know
obviously being Korean David being
Korean that's something you know we grew
up loving and then what we're preparing
next is going to be the Cassadine kimchi
fried rice we have the pork belly that I
smoked for six hours in here just going
to be ready kept ready in the oven and
then we have some 14 hours from crispy
coming up in a little bit hello welcome
welcome welcome welcome back everybody
by your side I Avilan buzz all around so
guys oh I know about good welcome
welcome welcome sit down have a
conversation talk was a lever you want
around you does mingle mingle mingle
share that I want you guys to try those
a bit we'll be having food coming up
soon
but what you can do to help me is start
plating the kimchi into the bowls and
I've got pork belly until bowls brisket
as well okay so I'm going to slice the
brisket so this is the cutie bowls hope
I don't bust this duck you're an
important part of this kitchen I am dude
I'm making all the food I'm special not
just a pretty face this I'm not just a
printer this is the fork our smoked
brisket easy me I'm just slicing and
chopping it all up so we can put it as a
side for you guys right
look at this beautiful piece right here
leave the jiggle the jiggle is going
into your mouth good I love him guy dude
dude open so lucky dude nothing no she
doesn't even like she's never turned my
fitness Jackpine she landed a jackpot
you cook you see Instagram post about
and muggy oh yeah
okay I'm gonna actually be this here
oh then there you go that's how good it
is speechless one shoulder really what
we wanted to put on the table was truly
what being a korean-american represents
its growing up eating your mom's cooking
you know your grandmommy homemade kimchi
your mom's you know just making kimchi
fried rice with a nice you know fried
egg on top I love that that's why
growing up I love going over to my
grandma's place being able to eat her
home like just home-cooked meal that
Junie has always resonated throughout my
life but on the other hand I grew up in
LA I grew up eating tacos I grew up
eating carnitas nachos
fast-food McDonald's Burger King you
know you name it so for me to have grown
with a very American upbringing as well
as a train operating in terms of food I
love being able to melt the tooth so for
me I've developed the passion for
barbecue I started you know fact yard
grilling ever since I was in high school
and now it's sort of evolved into
smoking barbecue and in Texas you know
you're smoking barbecue with just wood
you're just creating a fire on one side
of your smoker and the smoke and the
heat is going into your your chamber
your smoke chamber so that art form for
me I'm able to combine with my Korean
heritage so cast-iron kimchi fried rice
with the crispy bottom and the 14-hour
smoked brisket and the pork belly on top
with a runny egg to me that represents
Who I am and that's that's my heart on a
plate so that's why I really wanted to
do this dish in collaboration with David
because David has such a hard cord just
being unapologetic for who he is yes we
grew up in America but you know we can't
forget about who we are as Korean
Americans look at them they're all
mingling they're talking this is what I
like you should
have conversation get to know the people
around you even all this food look at
that smoked pork belly eat it just check
it Spence you'll see a nice steaming
spot right there you just be heard night
we love to take it Oh other than our own
man yeah oh it's for body or me
it's so weird when people give me stuff
even my parents they give me no part
thank you for us this dinner was very
special in the fact that we really
wanted to show this you know I hate the
word fusion and it's gotten a bad rap
but it's it's more of an amalgam it's
it's a combination of two cultures that
we grew up together into one dish so
that's that's really what it means for
me it's amazing so good what's your
favorite part oh I don't know I feel
like putting everything together is good
and then seeing David put it in like
little little containers with like the
best it's actually really nice I really
like the crispy part of the
I came out last time in with this I'm
doing this thing with less time in my
life where I don't eat meat for a month
and the meat looks amazing
but the rice is still good and egg is
good so it's nice is ready honey hole it
was amazing from the first part with a
deviled egg sounds like this was a your
favorite part of the experience you know
what to be honest to be meeting people
conversation yeah the conversation
because we're both older and we're like
you know it's harder to connect with
people not when we're in school it was
easy because you know you're meeting new
people are meeting people in general
every day and that's you get older it's
like okay it's work it was nice it's
nice people well we're going to end this
night pretty soon in a few minutes but I
just wanted to thank you guys for coming
out did you guys enjoy the food we're
like um once again I'm just gonna just
let you guys know I love this I love
sharing food with people and I love the
fact that you guys were opening up and
talking to other people too you know
this is something that I want you guys
to carry on as well when you go out to
eat that's perfectly fine too but my
thing is to try to make you put it on
it'll help you appreciate what you mean
it really will when you realize like the
amount of effort it takes for you to
create something and when you put it
into your body that's what she said it
helps you appreciate what you're eating
a lot more I started cooking at home a
lot more specifically because marks
making me but but it just it just helped
me a lot and that you'll get to know
people like this and seniors will see
you come up here
so all those pictures that you guys took
if you guys can please tag little meats
and then also you can greet hopefully
I'm gonna have more of these this is
just a test run and I think it turned
out really well right you guys got to
have bomb-ass food this the first time I
try to do if you saw my faith in my life
but share that experience with other
people try to have this I mean just
share meals with people have
conversation I started doing stuff like
this for example living out loud is
because one of the things that I
realized that people don't talk people
don't like to meet people any because
we're so focused on you know watching
David so comedy videos yeah but but uh
when you leave that part out and you
guys have conversations with somebody
else you don't have anything to bring
the table because you're not
experiencing life you know I have so
many stories because I was that weird
[ __ ] it just wouldn't I was going
everywhere you know hit me like I did a
lot of crazy things in my language wise
I always had something to talk about
always have something to share because I
like conversing with people it's just
one of those joys in life when you get
to connect with somebody else from a
different standpoint in yours
it's an amazing thing you guys can find
out how much good about yourself is
somebody else if you just open up so
what you guys did today was something
that was absolutely amazing
you saw strangers right in front of you
you shared a meal and you conversed
that's all it takes
all with the common bond of David so
yeah that's right we are family and you
guys are featured in the video now
even if you guys notice too like on my
videos like I don't really like
following trends I'm not that dude I
didn't start doing pranks when Prince
got popping I didn't start doing all
this other [ __ ] I like doing what I
like doing
whether people watch it or not is
allowed it's up to everybody else I
can't follow that stuff I got to do what
I love which is stuff like this which is
food connecting and talking living out
loud is an example of that when I first
put that out do you know how many
subscribers I lost when I start doing
the V out loud I lost like 6k
subscribers when I was like damn dude
that shit's harsh but what happens is is
that I stuck it out and I was like this
is what I love they all came right back
you got to stick with your guns you got
to be passionate about what you do
Stevie right here is an example of
passion did you know that he'll actually
learned how to cook from YouTube so
you're learning from a product of
somebody who took a platform that I'm
I'm also on and cream this amazing meal
and that's what I'm talking about that's
why I love social media to up to a
certain point - the trolls sometimes I
just want to meet them in person okay
every time they say something like yo
dude I swear to god David you ain't 1/3
gonna beat your ass I like let's do it
how did you do like I didn't know how
you to work there was people like
threaten to kick my ass and at this time
I was more of a I guess a rank
rambunctious child I literally call
people out I was like dude I'm gonna be
at this park right now let's meet up my
manner is like do what the [ __ ] are you
doing could you can't delete that
Coppola [ __ ] this [ __ ] let's do it turns
out the kids like 9 years old about the
fun let's do it
let's go well but thank you guys for
coming out thank you for sharing this
deal with me and you know hugs and
smiles all around when we do this again
maybe you guys get picked like hopefully
you guys will and maybe we'll spend this
out but you guys are a part of something
that we're just starting so thank you
once again and I'll talk to you soon I
feel good you know meeting everybody
here and sharing the meal this is what
it's really about - that's how much on
the food so little meets la check them
out if you guys want to go to Sunday
suppers or a lot of the other events
they have stuff with all these different
chefs is going to be little meets out
legacy in the description box below pick
them up and I'll see you guys at the
next eat
thank you guys for coming out man
remember remember this moment
I love
I told you my fans are just like me we
all love we just love too much